in 1942 the US Army Corps of Engineers
started building what is the greatest
model ever made so in 1927 America
suffered what Herbert Hoover called the
greatest peacetime calamity in the
country's history Great Mississippi
Flood it flooded seven states a half
million people were displaced ina cost
the country a third of their entire
federal budget at the time but mainly it
was just terrible and so the US Army
Corps of Engineers did what they do up
and down the Mississippi they built
levees everyone was like cool no more
flooding we tamed nature and then in
1937 it flooded again because every time
they built a levee somewhere that area
wouldn't flood but like a town just a
few miles down would be destroyed they
didn't understand how the river really
work corporal Eugene Raybould this guy
had a genius idea he was like why don't
we model and what this meant was
literally why don't we build a gigantic
model of it so the notion was let's make
a scale model a tiny version of the
entire Mississippi River Basin scale of
this model is is amazing it meant
building a model of 40% of the entire US
eight miles of tiny streams it's so big
you can't see it except from a plane or
a helicopter
cuz it's read out over 200 acres the
whole thing was a hydraulic model so
they could just pull a lever and run
through an entire flood I don't let them
put up little levees and figure out okay
if we put a levee here what happens down
the river they used it to stop a flood
in Omaha and save 65 million dollars at
the time it was also a wonder people
came to to visit it they came to stride
like Giants across the landscape you the
Army Corps of Engineers went to the
trouble of building little buildings and
making sure all the towns had names and
and so it was an incredible experience
and families would come to stride across
the land you could walk from the south
to the Midwest in five minutes six years
after they'd finished it they were done
the
test using the Mississippi River model
was run they didn't need it anymore they
left it they just walked away basically
and then they gave it to the city of
Jackson Mississippi and they didn't know
what to do with it they don't have any
money so they've literally just left it
rotting in the middle of the park where
it is today the Army Corps of engineer
is going to set out to build this model
but they also made this kind of
beautiful sculpture so today the tiny
little banks of the Mississippi are
slowly being overgrown with actual
foliage click here to subscribe or click
here to watch our other videos and it's
just it's awesome it's so cool it's like
it's like an engineers Disneyland
if you're ever in Jackson it's the thing
to do people have their little RC car
competitions there and it's great I
shall link to one of those RC car videos
at the end of this video here look at
here look at this RC car video